we talk a lot about player skill in
eSports and for good reason most of your
favorite games give stars plenty of
opportunity to show their supremacy the
Guardian comes back kick OH - they still
want to go there God we must plug the
bomb the peeps come in but Guardian will
not stop to go oh the games usually also
include a certain degree of the
unexpected the uncontrollable what we
all know as rng rng stands for random
number generator but the term has
basically become shorthand for any
randomized outcome in gaming and so when
someone complains about RNG they're
actually just complaining about luck
humans have had plenty of reasons to
generate random numbers for a while
[Applause]
bunch of hookers and cocaine sure you
can have someone just spouting off
numbers randomly three three seven zero
three one eight a two a two
[Music]
but people can have bias conscious or
not towards certain numbers no child of
mine is ever going to be named seven so
over the course of civilization tools
like dice have been created for this
purpose but not even the numbers
generated by dice are truly random dice
are physically and perfect and even if
they weren't they aren't a terribly
efficient way to generate random numbers
and without going too deep into math
even numbers generated by computers
aren't necessarily random if the
randomness comes from a set algorithm
the sequence can eventually repeat the
quest for truly erratic phenomena that
could be used as a basis for random
numbers led to the development of Ernie
in the 1960s not that Ernie I'm talking
about electronic random number indicator
equipment whether it's particles of neon
gas or atmospheric noise truly random
number generation uses a natural
unpredictable phenomenon to generate
digits can I stop talking about math I
went into journalism because I can't do
this [__]
wait are you sleeping so what does this
have to do with gaming and eSports well
the influence of RNG can be felt to
varying degrees there are games that
make no use of it at all those that
incorporate it sparingly and some that
have fully embraced it as part of their
identity and incredibly all three
variations have managed to produce and
maintain competitive eSports scenes but
let's talk about the extreme ends of
that spectrum first in rocket League RNG
outside of spawn locations play zero
role in how you experience the game as
it is entirely physics based
and well luck might have some impact on
how things pan out that luck is never
created outside the confines of the
players control
similarly overwatch is a title that so
far has chosen to avoid the lure of RNG
mechanics with its hero and map designs
while eSports purists might prefer to
let skill and teamwork determine victory
the absence of RNG in these types of
games can result in more predictable
outcomes on the opposing end of the RNG
scale we have the likes of hearthstone
an eSports title which has historically
embraced it perhaps more than any other
the most famous example of this is
Blizzard Entertainment's introduction of
yogg-saron hope send a card that casts a
random spell for each spell you've
already cast that game ok so it's up
forces money that should be getting
interface alright and what else do you
get so many animations stand against
darkness
my was huge
that was absolutely huge down Monsanto
has a gigantic board cleared all of
dudes major threats
doot-doot its face says alone while not
all random effects in hearthstone are as
crazy as yog cards like the humble
babbling book generate effects that can
be just as potent in the right
situations
oh my god the heartbreak on the face
ride home Bay's own hair a little bit
was so frustrated although the
randomness of hearthstone is undoubtedly
a key part of its appeal it can be
off-putting to those placing more weight
on purely skillful competition so
therein lies the challenge for game
developers how do you strike the balance
between keeping your eSport feeling
fresh for players and entertaining for
spectators while maintaining skill based
competition over the years Riot Games
has attempted to walk this proverbial
tightrope by implementing RNG into
League of Legends with mechanics like
Auto Attack crit chance
that's critic twice and even in champion
designs themselves like Twisted Fate but
in 2016 they introduced more RNG to
league with the addition of elemental
Drake's which at the time drew division
well I think the random dragon is super
vet for like competitive especially
competitive game it's really not that
bad because each of the dragons offers
different strengths it's just like you
have to play a different way like if you
get three infernal Drake's you can kind
of just group as five and crush the
other team but if you have three cloud
Drake's you have to be a bit more
nuanced maybe it's a split push and
rotate between the lanes like we could
literally not show on the bottom side of
the map and lose nothing but like 10 CS
and a cloud dragon and we can get rift
and top pressure for it and yeah I think
it's really bad riot explained that the
addition of RNG Drake's was an attempt
at ensuring game to game variation and
increasing the value of dragons as a
strategic objective whether they
succeeded or not remains up for debate
even valve has dabbled in RNG with both
dota 2 and csgo in dota most notably in
mechanics like ogre magi z' multicast
ultimate a passive that gives the
two-headed mage the potential for insane
burst damage and in csgo with the random
accuracy of your first bullet in a spray
here I have four BOTS my crosshairs
dressed on his head all right ready
here we go nope nope nope there we go
today RNG continues to be relevant and
that can be seen with the rise of battle
Royales an entire genre of games whose
design is steeped in the concept of
chance from the weapon and item drops
you discover to the randomly determined
final battleground on the map and how
could we not mention haded mechanics
like crosshair bloom in fortnight
[__] bloom is [__] amazing Wow
even out of game RNG remains inseparable
from eSports especially with the
continued growth of gambling even if
it's maybe not as random and sometimes
portrayed you know what I'm gonna bet
for money
oh but twenty on green oh my god I just
didn't accidental green bet oh my god I
just did an accidental green that oh my
god what the [__]
my disappointment is immeasurable and my
day is ruined it's easy to blame luck
for things and it leads some people to
thinking that eSports should have no RNG
at all but if the outcome of a game is
too certain as a spectator it might not
be very exciting to watch as a casual
player it might not be very fun to play
without just a touch of RNG some of our
favorite moments in eSports might not
have happened
here he comes once again the first base
is the [__] gonna hit the ground
there's cold so what is it about RNG
that can make people so angry one answer
might be that people are generally bad
at figuring out probabilities so even
though everyone should be affected
equally by RNG over time it feels like
you get screwed more often it's no
wonder that gamers often give thanks to
rnjesus when things go their way even
one of the greatest melee players of all
time
Adam Armada Lindgren felt rnjesus is
blessing on occasion evident would be
ridiculous amounts of bombs and stitch
faces his peach was sometimes able to
draw this game you know honestly a lot
of peaches right now will actually throw
the explosion is big wait what if you're
if you're 900 and why I use a bobble
we didn't Oh eat it too but he's going
for it
it's the anguish of a man who just saw
axe get stitched face six times but
that's not to say that RNG heavy games
don't require skill in fact they
challenge players to adapt to scenarios
outside their control is that elemental
Drake worth killing off the choke point
hobby stamps for takes a law that first
Punisher worth fighting over if it's the
subpar warder Punisher what are the
chances that the yog Sauron you played
blast your own face and back into the
Stone Age died by himself right I know
is getting absolutely trolled by yog
Charan right now discards an entire head
that just and what if you end up with a
director who's actually a hack with no
people skills deal with it exactly not
that not that Ernie I'm talking about
electronic random number indicator
equipment [__] obviously dude how could
you not know that [__] how could you not
be one of the 4,500 people that watch
this YouTube video already